[Music]
i was hoping you could just expand a bit
on what it looked like
what it meant for your father to choose
being a father as the talent he wanted
to cultivate and then the quality time
demanded quantity time as i think about
kids i don't have any yet this is of
interest to me
and my dad died two years ago
roughly as 89 years old
or in 1930
i actually would start with the
point about distraction because i think
it's about more than parroting
life goes by so quickly
and we let it
and somebody pointed out uh might have
been ryan holiday i think you know you
um
when you're on your deathbed what would
you give for
one more day with someone you love one
more
ice cream cone one more sunset it's
really trite but it's not tried at all
actually it's incredibly essential to a
life well lived
and you know there's a beautiful song
about it called may i suggest which i
recommend profoundly as a encouragement
to pay attention
and so we
we often don't you know
we miss the sunset or we see it and we
just we're too busy texting or we ate
the ice cream cone and we're talking
while we're eating it we're hardly
noticing it's going down it's compulsive
and i think
parenting
but more than parenting life
requires uh paying attention and um
you know my dad i would say my dad was
one of the least meditative people
who was born in 1930 there weren't that
many of them to be honest it's it's a
it's a more uh recent phenomenon but my
dad
had zero i went on three silent
meditation retreats while he was alive
and he found that utterly bewildering
so he was not a meditator
but he understood somehow that principle
about
paying attention to what's important and
what was important to him was us
his children and his wife and his family
and
as i said he used to complain he said
he said it's terrible he said god gave
me such a big soul
and so little talent i have so much to
say
and i can't say it he wanted to be a
poet he wrote lots of poems many of them
pretty good he liked a few of them
and his joke really was you read the
line but the joke was you know he'd like
to be a minor american probably didn't
want to be robert frost or anderson
malay
he would be happy to be a quieter person
with a couple good poems and he might
have achieved that if he had devoted
himself to that craft but he instead
devoted himself to us
one of my favorite things about my dad
when we had our kids and i'd say dad you
want to read a story you want to read a
book to want to you know one of my kids
he was so disdainful of that the idea of
reading a book that someone else had
written
was so cheating to him
all of his stories were made up he
he told us
hundreds of stories of my children
hundreds of stories that he crafted that
he made up and he could have been you
know a great children's writer he could
have been
maybe a minor american poet but uh he
spent most of his time with us his free
time
and uh does the quality time demanded
quantity time just
is that akin to to come up with a few
good ideas you have to come up with a
lot of bad ideas you just have to throw
a lot against the wall what does that
what does that mean
i think for those of us who are
ambitious who have big egos which is
sometimes me maybe you i don't know i'm
sure it's also me
right
you can
comfort yourself and i think sometimes
fill yourself into saying
well you know i don't give a friend x
family member y
situation z the trip to the hospital the
going to the funeral i don't do those
things because you know those take too
much time i got i have more important
things to do but when i am with them
it's quality time i really give them
myself
and i think what my dad believed and i
believed or tried to believe as a parent
for my four kids is that
quality time requires quantity time you
can't just turn it on you can't just say
okay let's have a serious conversation
go
it doesn't work that way
and we understand that about friendship
most of our friendships
take years
where we
experience things together do things
together have
intense conversations and the nth one
the last one the next one
is building on all of that and the idea
they can just say okay i'm here for you
and which is i think the the modern
impulse and it's good it's not bad it's
good to be here for people
but i think the quantity time part of it
helps us
cultivate that quality time get the hang
of it and it's certainly i think
i don't know if you ever spent a long
time with somebody on a lazy afternoon
it's just a different experience
you